okay we're back and here are the
questions of the people Bradley Whitford
how would your West Wing character Josh
Lyman know yeah
Lyman was the last name yeah I didn't
know that Josh ever yeah oh you would
know I remember would your character
West Wing character fare in the Trump
White House
what a crazy question how'd he fare yes
he wouldn't be in the trouble he's
stupid question number one really
Ryan Astrid Barack Obama be leading the
left into the midterms or is there a
better option I don't know if there's a
better option but the question I would
ask about that is you know Obama keeps
saying he's playing the long game
what's what's he waiting for it's about
I would I would hope that he would yeah
I mean now would be the time and I think
he will I think Obama would be very much
better it would be Michelle I think
though he may be the only choice by the
way for 2020 to solve your problems
probably the most popular woman in
America right yeah okay which would be
the best strategy for Dems in 2018
taking the high road or fighting dirty
we already answered that Michael Moore
which of your movies would you most like
to make a sequel to no kind of
interesting well sadly they're all still
relevant so I I mean you know I was
gonna ask you about Bowling for
Columbine in about guns yeah now that
fascism is coming to America and their
side has all the guns any second
thoughts
78 78% of Americans do not own a gun
right and they're all the liberals and
there's right there's 7 million
Americans that own 160 million guns they
have stockpiled them this is you this is
the elephant in the room in terms of the
discussion of what are we all going to
do putting our bodies in the line what
does that really mean we'll do it not
violently but we people are afraid
people
were afraid people who voted for Hillary
were afraid that she would win because
of he told my second amendment people
this is gonna be a rigged election
get ready get your guns he was calling
for an armed revolt if Hillary won and
ask yourself that question if had gone
the other way where where he won the
popular vote and she won the electoral
college that civil war would have
already happened no or and that's what
everyone's afraid of and we don't have
we don't own the guns but there's more
of us and I think the military is still
with the question and they've got bigger
guns and more guns and I never comes to
that but do you think the military snow
well it's a huge question actually huge
got that question he's the commander in
chief are you worried that that I got
that question from a sitting senator
when we were talking about the war in
Yemen and I was trying to talk him into
declaring it unconstitutional and
getting us out of the damn war and he
sent everybody out of the office and we
talked for a few minutes and he sort of
presented that to me Wow
it was in the terms of maybe a lost
massive loss in the midterms which I
don't think it's gonna happen now but
let's say it did and then impeachment
proceedings proceeded with haste from
both parties and Trump would then call
his legions into the street with their
guns and what would the military do and
frankly I couldn't answer it no I said I
don't you can't
I mean it's worrisome because for him
that we have to listen yes all the
constitute it's worrisome because the
military is in general conservative but
also because he is their
commander-in-chief here's an interesting
point though to sociologists did a paper
recently called a casualty gap they
studied the world war one world war two
Korea all the wars we have good down on
granular data on they found there has
always been an imbalance poor people die
of more than rich people everybody knows
that I think as a brain but in the last
17 years of war the gap has grown
astronomically so they wanted to see if
that had a political impact they went
and did a very fine poll with
controlling factors for other answers
and so forth came to find out that most
of the families who'd lost someone or
had someone wounded badly voted for
trauma
there's a political result of what we're
doing right now which is letting poor
people die overseas or get our bleed or
come back with post-traumatic stress for
all the rest of us the Republicans have
always had this amazing ability to be in
an abusive relationship with their
voters the more they hurt them yet the
more the voter yeah I had a teamster guy
in the Midwest he said to me that Trump
groomed economically vulnerable
Americans like a pet harassed like wow
like would a mr. said that yeah I was
like wow change his vanity in search for
love to fill the god-sized hole in his
soul which is not intelligence but it's
as inevitable as water rushing down a
hill right he will go for that love and
and yeah that's the that's the bait and
switch
what there's economic anxiety oh wow
blaming immigrants works you know that
turns it up and then you and I get a tax
cut that's that's you know the switch
given the commonality of threats Cameron
asks made on social media by mass
shooters should the government take a
more active role in monitoring these
sites not Donald Trump's government no I
really don't want to thing that I feel
more than Mark Zuckerberg as Donald
Trump so but you know we haven't talked
very much about what happened in
Annapolis the person who was fermenting
violence the most is the president the
United States Peter he's the crowd on
journalists a hooting hollering
screaming mass of people he individually
picks out journalists for them to direct
their ire he calls us the enemy of the
people he says that we are unpatriotic
that we do not love our country and were
surprised when someone picks I I feel it
on the street the way people drive angry
and I feel like more than ever they're
over the line like the line in the
middle of the road
I'm always honking like get on your
[ __ ] side of the road I don't know if
it's maybe some of that is texting but I
never I don't remember that before I
think I think they'll worse than anger
most people I think a lot of people in
this audience are filled with despair
and and well it was a bad week it this
was a week that it was like 1940 when
France fell it was like 70 AD when the
Temple of Jerusalem you know I mean if
that's how it felt if there's another
Impa thank you 87 defense these
conservative justices it bothers me the
Supreme Court throughout its history has
always shown a deference to national
security issues
it rarely weighs in on national security
issues whether it's the Patriot Act
unconstitutional Wars we're gonna get a
court probably that's gonna be even more
so that way and so that's more
supportive of the national security
state we have become the warfare state
we've become and that's very very
dangerous
that's what Eisenhower yeah today had to
remove a t-shirt that they have for sale
and the t-shirt said rope tree
journalist some assembly required and
enough uproar about it and they they are
not selling anymore what were they doing
selling it in the first place right and
I'm telling you it's but he has as
general the Trump has perpetuated this
yeah this level of calling for violence
and then that's where this civility like
I said to bend that's where the civility
debate if we're gonna get back to some
place we got to do it from let's not be
threatening each other and when I say
each other we're not doing it to them it
is unprecedented even presidents that
who I totally disagree with they won't
they did not actively want to separate
us this guy wants to separate us one
little piece of hope
my mother has been dead for a while but
she was born in 1915 earliest memory
everybody's dying from the flu she goes
to college the depression happens it
looks like this country doesn't work it
looks like Western civilization doesn't
work she gets married has two kids
Pearl Harbor happens she takes my dad
thinks she's never gonna see him again
it looks like Hitler's gonna win
it looks like Hitler's gonna win they
lived through that then McCarthyism
takes out you know poisons the country
she would say just understand well life
is [ __ ]
we we are used to a very comfortable
time and that is not normal and we have
to fight to defend those values you have
to but we can cut it we can come back we
come back because all those victories
Bradley that they occurred because women
took to the streets to get the vote
because my father and your mother joined
up in World War two all those things
that happens because people fought back
and and you know this is never gonna
come together unless people wouldn't
leave the boat it needs to go to Maine
and tell l.l.bean
and it means to surround the goddamn
capital and and maids tale Wednesday
[Laughter]
[Applause]